Tatort Meiningen der Fall häusliche
Gewalt Nachbarn haben die Polizei
gerufen
Zugriff bevor der mutmaßliche Täter
flüchten kann
das Opfer liegt blutend in der Küche
kaum ansprechbar Erste Hilfe
informiert eine Praxisübung für die
Anwärter der Polizeischule im
thüringischen Meiningen kein echter Fall
kein echtes Opfer aber zu echt wie
möglich hier in der sogenannten
tatort-welt lernen die angehenden
Polizisten Fälle zu lösen Recht
durchzusetzen zwei Jahre Ausbildung erst
Theorie dann viel Praxis
macht auf jeden Fall sehr viel Spaß auch
mal die andere Rolle zu spielen dann man
weiß ja als Polizeibeamter was man jetzt
ungern gegentreten möchte und dem kann
man halt nachgehen und halt sein
Mitschülern einfach zeigen
doch immer weniger wollen in den
mittleren Dienst der Polizei wo es auch
uns zu packen geht
die lernen an das Elend digitaler und
hier muss man bei Handwerk machen die
jetzt das Handy nicht viel
deswegen ist es manchmal so man muss es
tun machen jetzt praktisches Training
angesagt woanders ist es guten Hände zu
benutzen da kann man Informationen
abrufen aber hier nützt halt eher wenig
die Ausbildung anpassen die
Polizeischule in Meiningen hat für die
praktischen Trainings das reale Leben
nachgebaut Verbrechen werden überall
begangen im Supermarkt in der Kneipe auf
der Straße
4 sind am Einsatzort angekommen prüfen
jetzt den Sachverhalten
Einsatz für Lysann Zimmermann und Pia
Schatz der Fall Diebstahl aus diesem
Fahrzeug zuerst müssen Tatort und Spuren
gesichert werden nichts darf übersehen
werden
fallklärung im Unterricht
gut
Arbeit ist dass wir die Spuren so weit
aufnehmen können dass wir am Ende ein
Erfolg haben dass wir den Täter quasi
ergreifen können
Lysann vernimmt den Geschädigten für die
ehemalige Hotelfachfrau ist es die
zweite Ausbildung
offensichtlich auch aufgeben ich finde
es einfach toll anderen Menschen zu
helfen ein bisschen auch für Recht und
Ordnung zu sorgen was man bei der
Polizei er wirklich sehr gut kann und ja
ich finde es einfach toll mit Menschen
zusammenzuarbeiten den zu helfen bei
schwierigen Situationen und
es ist einfach ein tolles Team diese
zu lösen das gibt dann doch schon ein
gutes Gefühl und deswegen denke ich
schon dass man auch ja in unserer Rolle
sage ich mal sich gut fühlt und die Welt
irgendwo ein Stück weit verändern kann
junge Menschen wie sie für den
Polizeiberuf in Uniform zu begeistern
wird immer schwieriger und damit auch
die Klassen zu fällen guten Morgen
im Herbst sind 190 Anwärter fertig und
arbeiten dann in den Thüringer
Polizeidienst Stellen 40 mehr hätten sie
eigentlich gebraucht
in der Tat hat es Jahre gegeben da waren
die Bewerber buchstäblich Schlange die
standen bei uns das hat sich mit der
Generation Y und Z grundlegend geändert
und deshalb sind wir wie viele andere
moderne und gute Arbeitgeber auf Werbung
angewiesen jetzt wird der Nachwuchs mit
Vollgas auf Schulhöfen umworben
auf allen Feldern ermitteln
Aufstiegschancen schaffen
[Musik]
Überraschung gut
ein neuer Imagefilm Kalender mit
Autogramm und Lysann die für die
Ausbildung wirbt an einer Erfurter
Gesamtschule anderthalb Millionen Euro
steckt Thüringen in die Polizei
Nachwuchswerbung der Streifendienst der
würde mich halt interessieren
ja weil
wir uns halt einfach so jeden Tag halt
einfach miterlebt was halt so los ist
und da halt mit dabei zu sein das würde
ich sehr spannend finden
Überzeugungsarbeit leisten mit Technik
begeistern den Beruf im Staatsdienst
erklären
auf irgendeine Art und Weise wäre es
schon was für mich weil ich das auch aus
der Familie und sowas kenne also meine
Mama arbeitet ja bei der Polizei
ich weiß nur nicht so mit Kindern und
sowas wenn den dann was passiert und so
ich weiß nicht ob ich das könnte die
Hundestaffel hat welche Arbeiten
auszuführen da gibt es verschiedene
spezialrichtungen hier haben wir den
personenspuren dann gibt es noch den
Pferden sucht
sprengstoffspüren da haben wir noch
rauschgiftführer und datenträgerspuren
brandmittelspuren und Leichen und hat
mitgespielt junge Menschen nach Jahren
des Sparens hat sich auch für den
Thüringer Innenminister Angebot und
Nachfrage gedreht der Arbeitsmarkt ist
nicht mehr so wie vor ein paar Jahren
dass wir zehnmal mehr Bewerbungen hatten
als wir Plätze haben und aus meiner
Sicht das ist ganz zentral dass wir
diverser werden das auch Polizei
Gesellschaft abbildet ja mit all ihren
Facetten vor allen Dingen brauchen wir
auch mehr junge Frauen aber wir brauchen
natürlich auch gesellschaftliche Gruppen
Menschen mit Migrationsgeschichte und so
weiter und so fort weil das ist zentral
für eine erfolgreiche Polizeiarbeit
ein Beruf mit angeknackstem Image
Montagsdemos Drohungen Gewalt
auch Situationen wie diese auf dem
Lehrplan der Polizeischüler in Meiningen
Staats- und Verfassungsrecht anwenden
Meinung ausblenden
merkt man halt das nicht jeder Erfolge
über die Polizei ist und
ja letztendlich müssen wir dann auch
einschreiten wenn dann die Leute
prinzipiell die Rechtsstaatlichkeit
anzweifeln das ist dann schwierig ein
Argumentationsgrundlage dazu finden und
mit den Leuten dann weiter im Dialog
auch zu bleiben denn der Polizist hat ja
auch als wichtiges Einsatzmittel seine
Stimme wichtig für uns ist dabei einfach
dass man das Ausblenden kann wir wissen
wenn eine Maßnahme rechtsmäßig ist und
dass wir die dann auch einwandfrei
durchziehen einfach ausblenden sich
davon auf keinen Fall ablenken lassen
Gegensätze Extremismus
demokratiebildung im neuen sozialen
Kompetenzzentrum der Polizeischule
Lysann und die anderen Anwärter künftig
als Kind der Gesellschaft sich schon in
der Ausbildung Auseinandersetzen mit den
Rändern was ist das was mir in den Kopf
kommt
ein demokratisches Selbstverständnis als
Grundlage des polizeiberufs
weil wir Garant für die Demokratie sind
das ist auch mit unserer Auftrag wir
stehen dafür wir sollten auch Vorbild
sein aber wir müssen uns aktiv damit
auseinandersetzen weil nur eine
Vorbildwirkung zu haben und nicht zu
wissen was dahinter steht ist ganz
schwierig und wir müssen sie auch
verteidigen die Demokratie
auch deshalb sucht die Polizei dringend
Ermittler wie sie